on va tout de suite retrouvé matthieu
delormeau on est en direct matthieu
delormeau il y avait une femme qu'il
aimait énormément
matthieu delormeau saramon mathieu tu
m'entends bon mathieu comment ça va mon
chéri je vous reçois de bronze soit bon
mon mathieu il ya une de ses plus
grandes fans qui s'appelle alexandra à
qui tu vas faire un toc toc toc a fait
partie de thé de leurs moeurs
tu va taper à sa porte je pense que
peut-être que maintenant siennes nous
regarde elle doit savoir que c'est toi
mais ça va quand même une surprise
énorme pour elles tu es devant chez elle
la mathieu tu peux croire pourquoi on
verrait nature ce que tu peut sonner eux
est-ce que tu connais à la nage mais je
sens la connerie non non non mais
mathieu y en a qu à arrêter de son cas à
caudry ici une vraie fan qui s'appelle
alexandra elle a 11 ans elle va être
très heureuse ou regarde alors la petite
sur le canapé avec un bon dos pour
l'instant parce que ses parents ont fait
exprès qu'elle ne voit pas la technique
bonsoir
alors à la petite alexandra elle et elle
sait pas qu'à ma du moins pour l'instant
ça va être une énorme surprise pour elle
regarder parce que ses parents ont tout
fait pour qu'elle ne sache pas il ya
mathieu qui est avec elle juste est-ce
qu'on peut couper deux minutes le bon
voilà parce que c'est bon est-ce que
mathieu nous entendez ou pas parce que j
entends pas bien mathieu nous entend pas
les entend pas mathieu est ce que tu
m'entends mathieu alexandre agdal côté
toile ne sait pas que c'est toi tu vas
et tu va enlever son bandeau je pense
que ça va être le plus beau cadeau que
sa vie nazis mathieu
non
[Musique]
puisqu'il est beaucoup
j'ai troqué tout c'est vrai enfin le fan
enfin une femme sérieuse
mon coeur est mignonne c'est vraiment
c'est pas une blague c'est vrai quoi
c'est trop mignon
cette fois c'est moi oui mais ça c'est
pas des conneries que j'expérimente av
oui tu avais vous tapez ou faisait
mouche sur nrj
j'avais vu c'était moi tu avais must a
alors laissé médiation sur nrj12 tout ça
autour c'est vrai et je suis un petit
peu tous les deux mais c'est trop mignon
c'est d'être est de taille qu'est ce que
tu aimes c'est moi le quai le charisme
ne céderons vrai ouais n'en avons pas
les lézards ont tous les deux mais c'est
tellement mignon est tellement chou
c'est vrai laissez-nous un petit peu
tous les deux bien sûr même apporter une
photo mais faites votre vie si vous
voulez un mini chez nous elle me bat si
c'est vrai oui tous les
[Applaudissements]
haddock
idem quand même battu rejeter mais
mathieu tu es fier de toi je matin
[Applaudissements]
mathieu la maladie nous avons envoyé une
vraie vidéo va vous montrer la vraie
vidéo d'alexandra la manne regarder le
saut salut abbas est en promo en fait je
rigolais j'aime pas du tout et mon rêve
c'est que tu exploses de chocolat que tu
lui en fait par tous ses amis soit sale
et qu'à la fin il ressemble à un
chocolat c'est ça mon rêve à l'examen
mathieu sachez en tout cas que je t'aime
et que tu est exceptionnel les jeunes
comme ça tu es beau même comme ça à des
loisirs
thomas ce que tu aimes tu es bien tu as
toujours tu as toujours un moment il ya
toujours une manière d'exprimer son
amour assez particulière merci match va
nous rejoindre à tout on revient sur
plein de jouets pour la lecture
et on lui a créé à l'action à jouer chez
mathieu de lambeaux et avoir un
smartphone elle aura les deux peuvent
soulever enfin smartphones et nature on
a battu
[Applaudissements]